[Musik]
herzlich Willkommen zu Murat 5 Minuten
endlich nach monatliche Abstinenz bin
ich wieder da und ich habe einen Gast
heute bei mir ganz ganz der mich richtig
stolz drauf und zwar der
Bundesverfassungsschutz kennt ihn des
CIA er war vier Jahre lang in Guantanamo
mein Kumpel Günni so
es macht richtig ein bisschen
ich habe immer ich habe Aggressionen
wenn du in meiner Nähe bist ganz ganz
Wichtiges zu sagen ist ich weiß das sind
viele jüngere Zuschauer zuschauen gehen
mich wir sind ziemlich beste Freunde es
war schon seit Jahren wir waren zusammen
in der ersten Klasse weil Günni wurde
erst mit 17 eingeschult ähm und wir sind
richtig gute Kumpels und das was wir
zueinander sagen meinen wir eigentlich
nicht ernst richtig doch ja okay und wir
durften auch lange nicht kochen weil die
Leute bei uns in im Unternehmen haben
einfach gemerkt dass immer wenn der
König ein Video machen dass der
Abonnenten verlieren ja und deswegen
Kanal genau und deswegen tut uns
eingefallen der abonniert diesen Kanal
nicht wir möchten nur Spaß haben wenn
ihr euch äh kein Interesse habt am Spaß
dann schaut euch die Videos
deine coole Geschichte so heute machen
wir ganz tolles Rezept und zwar es geht
um eine Super Bowl das Super Bowl steht
wieder an das ist wieder so ein ein
kleines für uns muss ich jetzt ganz
ehrlich sagen für uns Männer es ist
nämlich ziemlich cool wenn man sieht wie
sich 22 Leute den Kopf einrennen dann
lachen wir immer richtig schön ja das
macht richtig Spaß
genau und dann geht es dann um chicken
und es geht natürlich heute um corn dogs
weil das corn dogs sind halt schon mal
gegessen kann hast du nie gegessen
und zwar Günni war bei Militär bei der
berittenen gebirgsmarine da war er in
winnipek in Kanada und ähm war da
stationiert ein Jahr lang gell
dreieinhalb Stunden ja auf jeden Fall er
hat zu mir gesagt ja ich war ja weil
beim Maulwurf Druck
so unter der Erde der sieht nicht auf
jeden Fall fangen wir mit dem Rezept an
ganz ganz leckere kondox für den Super
Bowl und wahrscheinlich wird das Ding
während und das Rezept des Jahres sein
ja ich bin schon sicher ihr könnt diesen
Kanal hier abonnieren ganz ganz wichtig
bitte Abonniert diesen Kanal dass wir
vielleicht noch mal ein Video machen
dürfen eine ganz wichtig
wie nennen wir eigentlich diese Episode
wir nennen die diese Episode IQ unter
Raumtemperatur kochen
richtig frische für uns ja ich für dich
dann ja
dann fangen wir jetzt mal kurz an mit
den Zutaten sind ganz ganz easy ich
ziehe es euch mal auf was alles dafür
benötigt je nachdem wie viel Combox ihr
machen möchtet rindswürstchen oder
Wiener ich empfehle aber eher die Wiener
rindswürste ist nämlich nur mal zum
Ausprobieren
und ein bisschen Gouda am Stück
130 Gramm Stärke
130 g Weizenmehl
und hier ganz wichtig ein Teelöffel Salz
ein Viertel Teelöffel Knoblauchpulver
1/4 Teelöffel Zwiebelpulver 1/4
Teelöffel Cayennepfeffer ganz wichtig
nimmt da wirklich den Cayennepfeffer ein
bis zwei Teelöffel Backpulver
dann haben wir hier zwei Esslöffel Öl
2 Bio-Eier hier ist es ganz ganz wichtig
dass ihr die Bio Eiern nimmt weil sonst
funktioniert das Rezept nicht
200 Milliliter Buttermilch auch ganz
cool wenn ihr keine Buttermilch habt
könnt ihr eventuell auch Milch nehmen
mit Buttermilch schmeckt einfach besser
und natürlich ganz wichtig beim Korn dog
Holz schachtspieße hier ist ganz wichtig
dass diese Schaschlikspieße FSC
zertifiziert sind sonst funktioniert
ziemlich auch nicht und dann können wir
loslegen oder ja weißt du was mich
fasziniert wie du dir die ganze Zutaten
merken kannst und die um die Grammzahlen
und alles ist oder Wahnsinn ja
nicht hoch intelligent und ich habe mich
ein sehr sehr großes Hirn deswegen kann
ich mir das alles machen ja
[Gelächter]
hast du jetzt in die Pfanne hauen müssen
nein so ich muss auch ganz ganz ehrlich
sein ihr kennt Günni und mich und auch
die Neurowissenschaftler kennen Günni
weil sie an ihn versucht durchführen
wollte gerade sagen also das Rezept ist
nicht von uns so ehrlich müssen sein
weil ich meine ich will echt ehrlich
sein ich habe da echt ein Problem zu
lügen ich meine dein Leben ist auch
Lügen aufgebaut ähm deswegen ist es für
dich normal ja nein ja und deswegen
möchte ich euch auch jemand vorstellen
es war sehr gute Freundin
Arbeitskollegen zusammenarbeiten
wirklich eine Koryphäe im Kochen und
Backen ist und zwar hat diese Person
schon ganz wichtig diese Person hat
schon zwei Sterne gekocht also wir haben
hier wirklich im Team einen da würde
sagen zwei Sterne hoch oder einmal
jemals einmal ein Sternzeichen genau
auf jeden Fall die Chore Fee er hat uns
dieses Rezept mal zusammengestellt er
hat gesagt es ist idiotensicher das
können die zwei machen und hier ist euer
Dennis genau das hier ist Dennis also
wirklich Dennis
[Applaus]
unser Kumpel der hat uns dieses Rezept
gemacht dann ist das heißt wir kriegen
es auch hin richtig richtig auf jeden
Fall den also es ist sehr sehr einfach
und deswegen habe ich es für euch
gemacht also ich habe nämlich keine
Probleme ich weiß ja Dennis was für dich
sehr sehr einfach ist es für ihn sehr
sehr schwer
ich habe meinen Betriebsrat eigentlich
schon beantragt das ist eigentlich
besser gewesen wäre vielleicht ein
Schimpansen
interessiert Spaß gehabt
das ich bin ganz ganz fest davon
überzeugt und falls ihr Fragen habt dann
einfach okay ich rufe dich okay also wie
gesagt ganz cool
der hat zwei Stellen was hast du
Zahnstein
[Musik]
okay alles klar also fangen wir an mit
den mit dem allererst mit dem Würstchen
richtig ja genau aber Würstchen und zwar
wirklich Wiener Würstchen
genau die hast du besorgt diesen halal
ja du weißt wenn sie nicht Highlight
sind kommen wir nicht in den Himmel
ja hallo Julia ja Halleluja ja genau auf
jeden Fall könnt ihr hier Wiener
Würstchen nehmen das sind Geflügel
Wiener ganz wichtig und wir haben noch
zum Versuch haben wir noch
rindswürstchen geholt und da und die tun
wir schon mal aufspießen erstmal einen
kleinen schneiden
verschiedene Varianten und gucken was am
besten funktioniert so das machen wir
jetzt
das sind 20 cm
[Gelächter]
jetzt haben wir hier die Würstchen
wirklich ihr könnt wirklich jedes
Würstchen nehmen ihr wollt und wir
machen jetzt wirklich verschiedene
Varianten wir machen einmal an corn dog
mit einem ganzen Würstchen dann machen
wir die Hälfte mit dem Würstchen und die
Hälfte mit Käse und dann tun wir auch
mal ein Stückchen mal gucken welche
Variante am besten ist du kannst ja
schon mal aufspießen
ich bin ungefähr 20 cm größer ja genau
so dann nehmen wir zwei Würstchen und
einfach nur aufspießen hier dann immer
ein Würstchen wo man die Hälfte machen
hast du gerade einen Schlaganfall
[Gelächter]
das muss das
wir hätten Imbissbude wir werden schon
pleite weil du gerade mal das erste
Würstchen aufgestellt werden
ohne Witz
jetzt mal ohne Spaß wenn dann
Bewegungsmelder wird die mal reagieren
zu langsam wie du bist genau
das muss zack gehen musst mein beruflich
machen müssen das ist zack zack und die
Leute stehen die Schlange kommen sie
wollen ihre Würstchen haben genau nicht
streicheln was machst du da sag rein und
fertig so dann die Hälfte wir machen das
ich mache den Käse die müssen wir jetzt
machen so ja okay
so und dann oben Käse genau unten das
Würstchen oben den Käse dass wir den
Grad genau und jetzt den Käse
die Hälfte
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
und auch die andere Wurst genau
so macht genau die Rinde weg ich habe
vor die Rinde vergessen wegzumachen
weißt du es aber egal schauen wir
versuchen so perfekt und immer du weißt
immer ein Stück frei lassen dass man
noch hin greifen kann okay dann haben
wir das jetzt auch und jetzt machen wo
man zwischendurch noch was machen
ja aber du hast doch einen du hast eine
große Klappe das ist das andere weißt du
bei dir mundgerecht was ganz anders du
könntest doch eigentlich das Würstchen
könnte fast schon quer reinschieben kann
das sein
Amazon Amazon
[Gelächter]
genau und zwischendrin immer Käse so gut
und und
[Musik]
so guck mal so muss es aussehen guck mal
das sieht alles so einfach aus aber hier
ist ganz wichtig hier oben den Spieß
nicht rausschauen lassen es ist rund
wird und am besten den Wurstzipfel auch
oben das ist nachher schön rund aussieht
du kannst so schwer sein ein Würstchen
aufzuspießen oder du kannst dich schon
Probleme bei Würstchen aufspießen haben
ein Problem so du redest das ist Plural
nee Plural Plural ist in Russland aha
wenn ihr diese Combox veganisieren
möchtet dann könnt ihr auch so ein Käse
nehmen so ein veganen Käse nehmen
richtig so ein monokäse
genau haben noch nie probiert aber es
gibt auch vegane gut schmeckende
Würstchen habe ich recht hast schon ein
gegessen aber warum nicht du dann wieder
gelogen dein Leben ist auf Lügen
aufgebaut so so schön vorziehen genau du
musst gar nicht du musst einfach
Würstchen ziehen das kann schon länger
machen
man weiß nicht ob es corndogs sind oder
pondock sind ich weiß nicht
oh mein Gott so während wir jetzt die
Marinade machen tun wir schon mal was
vorbereiten und zwar das Fett das Öl
genau und das tun wir hier in dieser
Gusseisenpfanne machen aber wenn
natürlich nicht Fritteuse Heimat ist es
besser oder ein hohen Topf weil da
können die Combox gerade einfach nur so
reinstecken wir haben das leider nicht
deswegen nehmen diese Gusseisen Panne
und jetzt müssen wir wirklich so viel
rein tun dass der Korn komplett benetzt
ist und dazu tun wir es einfach
reinschieben richtig schön auffüllen so
dass der kornblock richtig schön nachher
richtig überall benetzt ist so die
Preise vom vom Sonnenblumenöl
heruntergegangen ich kann mich noch
erinnern das hat meine 79 Cent 80 genau
und ganz wichtig das Fett nachher bitte
wieder in der Flasche sammeln das könnte
wieder verwenden ja nicht in den Abfluss
ansonsten riecht richtig übel
ja das wie weit das ist doch wieder bei
deinen Arterien gell du hast doch so
eine
Fettleber hast ja
gerade das war zu zeigen muss so teuer
war dann habe ich meine Niere verkaufen
okay
[Gelächter]
ich glaube das reicht ja das warte mal
und jetzt ist es ganz wichtig dass es
Fett mindestens 180 Grad hat deswegen
tun wir schon mal vorheizen so
Fang trotzdem mal ganz kurz an auf Stufe
5 und dann gehen wir langsam hoch 180
Grad wir haben hier leider kein
Thermometer aber ich habe eine coole
Idee es gibt einen Trick wenn du den
Finger da reinsteckst und es fängt an zu
Blasen zu werfen dann nicht genau die
richtige Temperatur könnte es vielleicht
machen ja
das kannst du machen ja okay einen
anderen Tipp ist zum Beispiel hier so
ein Schaschlikspieß zu nehmen und dann
rein zu stecken und wenn er merkt wenn
ihr merkt dass da richtig so Blasen
rauskommt dann ist sie ungefähr die
richtige Temperatur
das hat mir Dinger erzählt der Dennis du
glaubst ja ich glaube alles okay
und jetzt geht's wirklich um die
Marinade die ist ganz ganz einfach HIER
tun wir zuerst die flüssigen Zutaten
hier rein darf ich rein schicken du
rührst ja weil ich finde
beim Berühren kann ich nichts falsch
machen aber man rein genau ja beim
reinstecken kann man richtig viel falsch
machen und zwar nehmen wir erst die
flüssigen Zutaten und dann die trockenen
die mussten wirklich langsam reinmachen
weil sonst fängt an zu Klumpen kann es
sein dass es bei dir auch geklumpt hat
kann es sein ist aber auch extrem schlau
wirklich ich weiß selber überrascht für
das wissen was ich hier habe ich bin wie
ein wandelndes Lexikon ja zwei drei zwei
okay also erst die Buttermilch und wie
gesagt Buttermilch schmeckt richtig
lecker wenn es nicht habt könnt ihr auch
Milch nehmen
so dann sage ich dir unterschiedliche
Buttermilch und Milch
schreib mal anders Butter drin
so die zwei Eier
des Öl Sonnenblumenöl
genau
okay
dann machen wir gerade das Salz rein
dann
das Zwiebelpulver
zwiebelpuder gehört wirklich in jede
Küche hier ist ganz wichtig ich könnte
keine frischen Zwiebel machen weil die
wird nachher wirklich bei marinieren im
Fett verbrennt
und dann werden sie leicht bitter dann
kriegen sie so eine säugigen Geschmack
ist aber so eine Kopfnote und wenn es
nach unten zieht ja war ein Spaß ich
wollte nur ein bisschen auf Sternkopf
machen so ich wollte einen auch auf
Dennis machen jetzt hier so dann gehen
wir weiter Knoblauch
Pulver genau und hier ist nochmal
Cayennepfeffer so ganz wichtig kein
schwarzen Pfeffer nehmen richtig
scheiden
das hat so ein bisschen andere Schärfe
so und jetzt dann noch das Backpulver
[Gelächter]
fangen wir an
langsam oder
du merkst das ist
ein Fehler gemacht oh Mann ab dem 17
februar ist Dance wer cool wenn ihr
einschaltet und sie bleibt unterstützt
[Musik]
das ist eigentlich wie so ein
Pfannkuchenteig und es ist wirklich
wichtig dass der ein bisschen
dickflüssiger ist und wenn ihr merkt
dass er zu dickflüssig ist machen und
ein bisschen Buttermilch oder wenn ihr
nichts mehr habt ein bisschen Milch oder
ein bisschen Wasser mit rein
du schnarchstunde japanischer Wasser
normal
das ist echt so eine Art wo ich habe
Angst
[Gelächter]
ich habe einfach Angst dass du mir die
ganze das ganze Backpulver einsaugst
ich eigentlich wie ein Pfannkuchen muss
man sagen hast du in deinem Leben schon
mal Pfannkuchen gemacht
[Gelächter]
und das Backpulver machen natürlich auf
das Ding dass der Teig ein bisschen
aufgeht
das war doch Backpulver
ach Gott okay die Stärke machen wir halt
auch rein das ist halt das weißt du in
so einer scheidet der eine hat hinten
genau und er tut mir leid es war kein
backpuls war Stärke und ich Stärke wird
reingemacht für die Konsistenz des Tages
weil es sollte kein Pfannkuchen sein der
so ein bisschen lätschig ist sondern der
kann doch schon so ein bisschen knackig
sein so richtig schön frittiert deswegen
machen wir die Stärke rein genau eine
cremige feste Konsistenz nicht zu
flüssig ganz wichtig weil das muss
richtig schön den ganzen kornblock wenn
er benetzen die ganze Wurst jetzt haben
wir gerade gemerkt dass der Teig noch
nicht so klebrig ist es war noch mal 35
bis 40 g machen wir noch dazu also merkt
euch das nee Entschuldigung noch 35 bis
40 Gramm machen wir noch dazu perfekt
das tun wir dann einfach im Rezept
nachher im Blog noch mal noch dazu
schreiben
ist jetzt richtig schön klebrig reicht
es jetzt aus
genau
okay so jetzt haben wir den Teig
zusammen
jetzt haben wir einen coolen Trick
vielleicht hat es zu Hause auch ich
hoffe ihr habt einen spritzbeutelständer
wie kommt es langsam echt voll dass wir
hier nicht Pornos machen wir haben hier
einen spritzbeutelständer und diesen
spritzbeutelständer füllen wir jetzt mit
dieser Masse
wenn ihr daheim kein spritzbeutelständer
habt dann könnt ihr einfach irgendwas
anderes nehmen vielleicht auch ein Glas
etwas etwas höher wurde die dogs
reinstecken könnt so jetzt haben wir
hier in den Spritzbeutel passt auf
entweder den Spritzbeutel oder was wir
auch haben ist zum Beispiel so eine
Karaffe finde ich auch cool so muss er
eine Karaffe machen finde ich echt
cooler so jetzt tue ich das Heben und du
holst raus du tust rein so jetzt haben
wir jetzt hier drin wie gesagt
vielleicht hatten daheim eine Blumenvase
von der Mutter wenn ihr irgendwie merkt
ihr braucht noch ein bisschen Teig dann
müsste ein bisschen mehr dazu geben ein
bisschen Flüssigkeit das kriegt ihr hin
schmeckt übrigens richtig cool mit dem
cayennepfer ganz ganz wichtig so jetzt
machen wir folgendes das riecht schon
richtig nach Fett normal
und zwar Beispiel wie das nennt man
nennt es an doppelt gewendet frittiert
egal ich wollte nur was sagen
so das machen wir warum damit nämlich
wenn ich jetzt hier drin Wende dann
bleibt es noch besser hängen verstehst
du das die Flüssigkeit klebt sich an
hast du verstanden
so jetzt habe ich das hier haben wir
vielleicht einen länglichen Keller
obwohl es geht funktioniert so jetzt
kommt drauf an
[Musik]
und jetzt
pass auf warte kurz Helfer Günni
wow
drehen irgendwas zum Drehen oh mein Gott
vielleicht noch ein bisschen Öl
reinmachen aber mach hier rein weil das
sonst kühlt es ab
du merkst auch das Öl ist noch heiß
genug ist blubbert schon richtig
[Musik]
so jetzt einfach brutzeln lass es bis es
richtig schön goldgelb sind wie Chicken
Nuggets
genau
dann die Marinade nicht mehr also da
wird ziemlich dicke Würstchen genommen
haben und ziemlich viel Käse hat er sie
Marinade nicht gelangt tut mir einfach
einen Gefallen macht einfach immer die
doppelte Menge macht die doppelte Menge
vom vom ganzen Rezept was den Teig
betrifft ich schreibe es auch so in dem
Block dass es im Video anders ist nimmt
die doppelte Menge wir sind keine Profis
[Musik]
und bitte ganz ganz vorsichtig mit Fett
hantierende Spritzen nämlich mit heißem
Fett genau kann es sein
[Gelächter]
ich drehe die Dinger mein Gott
wie in der Schule nichts gelernt habe
dann merkt euch einfach wie man die
Würstchen dreht sehr schön cool aus
probieren wir mal nee warte du musst
echt warten weil wir warte auf mich
warte bis alle fertig sind
ganz ganz wichtig und allgemein bei
frittierten das kann ich jetzt schon
sagen frittiert wenn was frittierte das
hat immer warm ist wirklich wenn Pommes
abgekühlt schmecken sie nicht fett hat
es ist ein ganz ganz andere Geschmack
ist aber vielleicht zu heiß bringen bis
mal probieren nein
abgetropft ist
und was ich auch gemerkt habe das mit
dem Tee oder zum Käse ist schon geil aus
man merkt schon mit Käse so ein bisschen
rausläuft natürlich wenn nur ein
Würstchen drin ist von der Form her auch
viel appetitlicher aus guck mal ich
merke es auch hier das ist ein richtiger
Korn dog siehst du das von der Form her
ja aber ist doch egal die Form ist doch
egal Hauptsache schmeckt ja perfekt aber
wir lassen noch ein bisschen Natur die
Abteilungen sind
von von Käse und Wurst jetzt mal ganz
ehrlich wenn du jetzt so ein kornblock
kriegt das so aussieht wenn du den so
gemacht hast dann wünsche ich Dir doch
ruhig beschweren das finde ich das jetzt
in Ordnung ja wenn er selber gemacht
hast nein
kommt mir nur Aussehen
ansonsten
es kommt nicht aufs außen es kommt im
Inneren Werkern ja
der nächste und einfach auf dem
Küchentuch hier schön abtropfen lassen
der ist auch fertig
[Musik]
manchmal manchmal geht es wirklich so
eine Frage bei Werkzeugen bei meiner
Frau ich frage mich für was braucht man
es eigentlich jetzt habe ich es
verstanden und zwar das ist so eine
Schaumkelle und das braucht man wirklich
um sein Fett zu reinigen ihr seht da
kann man alles rausholen oder wenn man
zum Beispiel Spätzle macht gerade
Spätzle immer die rausholen möchte aus
dem heißen Wasser deswegen sind diese
Dinger da Wahnsinn du hättest jemanden
brauchen kann sogenannte Fettkiller
ich kann das auch dass du vielleicht
auch eine brauchtille so
so macht man nämlich gerade das so hält
das Fett kann auch mehrmals benutzen
wenn man gerade diese schwebenden
Teilchen rausholt dann werden die auch
nicht schwarz
fertig
so
also ich will ich sagen in diesem
Spritzbeutel cooler ihr seht auch das
geht ratzfatz Zack und rausziehen
dran macht also ohne Käse das sieht es
nachher auch richtig cool aus aber das
kommt nicht aufs Aussehen an sondern auf
den Geschmack genau das ist ja dein
Motto es kommt nicht aufs Aussehen an
ich stelle dein motivieren ja genau und
so sehen sie aus frittiert richtig cool
ganz wichtig warm essen warm schmecken
ist richtig cool und jetzt gebe ich euch
noch einen folgetipp das haben wir
vorher vergessen und zwar wir hätten
vielleicht erst die Soßen fertig machen
müssen wenn man die Soßen fertig haben
kann sich auf die Seite stellen und dann
die corndogs machen und wenn Sie fertig
sind sofort die warmen Kontext mit der
Soße zusammen verspeisen jetzt müssen
wir schnell noch die Soßen machen die
Soße ganz ganz einfach da müsste
wirklich viel machen ich könnte euch
jetzt in einzelnen Bestandteile setzen
aber ich gebe euch mal ganz coolen Tipp
für Soßen das machen wir jetzt kurz okay
also wir machen jetzt wirklich zwei
verschiedene Soßen und zwar machen wir
eine Tomate Schafe und dann eine eine
würzig milde Weise so richtig rot weiß
ganz ganz easy Tomatenketchup hat jeder
von euch zu Hause das hier kennt ihr
auch das kennt normalerweise jeder
findet ihr jeden türkischen Laden das
gibt es auch bei Lidl es gibt inzwischen
überall das ist so eine thailändische
Soße so eine richtig scharfe Günni
einfach nach Geschmack zusammen mixen
und ich habe hier eine coole Mayonnaise
und eine Remoulade
und es könnte wie nach Geschmack machen
die zaumäßig schnell einfach aufmachen
die ist schon auf super
einfach Geschmack
genau
hast du gerade haben wir so viel
corndogs okay
und dann die Remoulade dazu also das ist
sauber ist da dreht meine Frau immer
durch wenn der Verschluss da oben
dreckig ist
und jetzt richtig schön zusammen Mixed
und jetzt können nach Belieben ihr könnt
noch von mir aus der schwarzen Pfeffer
reingeben mit dem Bock habt oder von mir
ein bisschen Dill aber die schon
ziemlich weit fertig ist schon ziemlich
fertig so
ich glaube ich mal ein bisschen mehr
wenn ihr jetzt wenn jetzt meine Frau da
haben wir die würde die ganze Soße
nehmen und meine Frau würde es in den
Spritzbeutel reinmachen damit es nachher
richtig schön Ding machen kann aber bei
mir faul sind machen wir nicht wir sind
auch so dumm und Spritzbeutel zu
benutzen habe ich recht keine Zeit ja
vom Gefühl her ja also danke schön
[Applaus]
voll cool meine ich auch richtig würzig
deine Schaf meine ich
da tun wir die Löffel tauschen
richtig cool richtig cool boah wieso
kann man doch eigentlich zusammen mixen
und dann guck mal das kann ich
eigentlich verkaufen weil ich finde das
viel cooler Tomaten
okay jetzt tun sie garnieren
das machen wir es natürlich fürs Bild
müssen wir jetzt schon schön machen so
jetzt haben wir diese Platte hier
diese corndogs
in die schönen runden ja genau
das Bild ist ganz wichtig aber komm pass
auf wir machen eine mit den schönen
genau
die geben wir zum fotografieren
die lassen wir jetzt vom fürs Foto
lassen wir das von Dennis so richtig
schön machen okay die Sonne Dennis
und für uns kommt ihm einfach seine
Platte
das ist für uns richtig zum Probieren
wirklich schön aussehen wirklich ganz
hässlich aus aber die schmecken
wahrscheinlich ganz toll ja ja
[Gelächter]
ja so die ist für uns
und was hast du machen wir sind ja
[Musik]
jetzt pass auf
machen
und ich glaube ich bin eigentlich fast
sicher dass auf dem Foto sind es die die
mit den nur Würstchen und die haben wir
Käse und Würstchen die sind richtig
lecker aus genau Löffel
[Musik]
okay geil oder nein mann das ist kein
Termin Video das ist unser Video wir
müssen es nicht so guck mal
der soll jetzt richtig irgendwie sowas
machen guck mal das ist hässlich aber es
ist ehrlich
so dann machen wir noch paar Zwiebeln
drüber guck mal selbst die Zwiebeln
würden meine Frau jetzt selber machen
wir haben jetzt fertige
Röstzwiebeln geholt aber jetzt einfach
drauf guck mal so das ist Real Life das
ist das ist echt eng ja wir sind Männer
los boah so und das geben wir jetzt den
Dennis damit er die coolen Bilder machen
kann
nicht ohne mich an warte kurz
das haben wir so schwer zu warten so
okay jetzt komm probier einfach sei
einfach glücklich Mama hat ich laufe
einen Käse haben
geil ja das Footballspiel wer will ein
Footballspiel ich will jetzt
ich habe nie gelebt
guck mal jetzt musst du erst 75 Jahre
alt werden bist du mal das erste Mal ein
Konto gegessen hast
ich verstehe es die Amerikaner ich
verstehe sie wirklich nur warum gibt es
bei uns gibt es nur Döner Stände und
Currywurst warum gibt es nicht sowas tut
mir gefallen macht es nach wirklich ohne
Spaß das ist ein gamechanger für dein
Leben verändert
alles klar mir ist jetzt fertig ihr seht
jetzt noch das tolle Bild vom Dennis wie
es angerichtet hat macht die doppelte
Menge von Mehl kommt halt wirklich die
Menge von mir gekommen bin ich auf die
Würstchen an wir hatten es gab sieben
Würstchen mach da doppelte Menge und
dann könnt ihr euch wirklich überlegen
ob es in den spritzbeutelständer fand
ich am besten muss ich ganz ehrlich
sagen das mit der Nase war nicht so toll
wir können auch die Menge von der
Würstchen machen
der abonniert den Kanal nicht guckt euch
die Videos ganz ganz toll hier ist noch
mal der abonnierten abonniert den Kanal
und ich hoffe dass wir keine Abonnenten
verlieren und dass wir in Zukunft wieder
weiter neue Videos machen okay genau
Kochen auf geringen Bildungsniveau wir
sehen uns macht's gut tschüss
kommen aus Korea das wusste ich gar
nicht machen ja
jetzt mal ohne Spaß wenn ich so müsste
es mit unserem Stand geben mit mit mit
Metall Würstchen und so weiter Hammer
also schreibt's mal in die Kommentare ob
es aus Amerika oder aus Korea kommen
[Musik]